Alright. Before we get started on the class project,
this lesson's assignment will allow you to get comfortable with
the type of work that data scientists do using
a small and classic data set. This data set describes
the riders on the Titanic and a bunch of
information about them. For example, what class they were in,
whether they were male or female, how old they
were, etcetera. Over the course of the assignment, you'll build
a few different models. The models will
start out simple, but they'll get increasingly complex.
To see if using data science, we can
predict who will survive and who won't survive
the Titanic tragedy. This may sound complicated, but
don't worry. We'll give you plenty of help.
This assignment is meant to get you in
the habit of thinking like a data scientist.